Let us look at it in context, I mean, so let's say, that's something like 20 years more, 25 years of the UK science budget.
That's how much that is, a quarter of a century of UK science spending.
Now in that time, spending that money, UK engineers have done things like we... I mean, CERN is an example.
We've invented, we invented the World Wide Web, which revolutionized the world.
The list is endless. I mean we, you know, modern era engine technology, life expectancy is increasing beyond anyone's expectation.
This is how they'll spend.
We're talking about single figure billions in research budgets, in every government, all across the world.
I mean the UK actually is a very successful and very efficient spender of money but the research budget is about three billion.
Three billion pounds, think about that.
And then, compare that to what Apple have got in the bank account.
So you're absolutely right. Apple as a company...
...could reignite a Victorian age of engineering.
Right there they could do it because that's the amount of money you need to do it.
So I, yeah, I agree with you completely, we need a shift in the way that we think about investment and R&D.
Should they do it?
Well, I think they should and their shareholders might have some objection, but that is the way.
This is why government has a key role because the role of government in my view is to allocate capital in the economy for the good of everybody...
...and not just for the good of the shareholders.
So, some combination, some way of investing more money on this which is self-evidently the thing that we need to do.
Not only as the UK or the US or wherever you're watching this program, as a civilization, it's obvious that we need to invest more in engineering and R&D.
You need a big industrial import and I'm thinking that some of the great discoveries, I mean look at the transistor, for example.
That's always been associated with Bell Labs, this great US industrial research facility.
What crucially, I think there's a lesson here, because that was curiosity led research.
And I think one of the problems we occasionally have, or often have actually, is that industry can tend to be very focused.
There's a very famous quote often raised, which is that, "The electric light wasn't invented by continuous R&D on the candle."
You needed some step changed.
And so, I think as long as, you don't, industry is not purely associated with this targeted research, it's driven to particular problems.
And indeed actually government-funded research because government falls into this trap, it's one of, it's a terrible trap to fall into.
What you need really, is you need engineers, you need scientists.
You need to let their curiosity run wild.
You need to let them to go and play, literally play on the edge of our knowledge.
And time and again we found whether that's in a big lab...
...or big industrial setting or government-funded setting or even a single person in the university or elsewhere,...
...when you allow that to happen, then you get paradigm shifts which change everybody's life.